okay I'm actually joining early this
time they've only played one game Magnus
has actually played a lot today and so
has Segal Co this pawn looks dangerous
you probably have to woo he complains
King c1 I would have just taken and
tried to survive that game with the time
but it seems like White's very close to
getting mated like the pawns just gonna
run down so it's up to White's like
dirty flag black battle Knight takes c3
I've sobbing the counter-attack there's
no meat just yet but me that's coming in
two moves so he's gonna run yeah don't
leave on cloud oh did black have amazing
one in the final position Queen g1 was
made in fun that's the worst time to
flag is when you're on the Virgin
meeting what is this opening oh it's a
fright liver it's a real fried liver
Magnus being so grave with his King the
stream is just beginning
and he's being yeah so so brave but this
seems really dubious I mean especially
to play and bullet like I would
understand playing this in my
correspondence but bullet chess your
Kings on e6 okay now it's slightly
better you wanna play Bishop u6 hello to
people in the chat yeah if you're
joining you're joining early Magnus has
already won two games and Oh king g6
what is this
so he went like this this and this but
he's still up a piece still up the piece
I have to say goodnight to not allow
taking on d5 but this looks really bad
for black I mean the knight barely
covers g3 but now the knight spin so
this is a threat I mean still this just
oh the Queen pins are rook
but the knight is attacked
a very dubious open twice Hey hello
again was this if he if he dirty fides
again that would be amazing green still
cards each three maybe g6 you wanna uh
creates there's an escape route for the
King now you just want to throw moves
like rook c8 maybe Magnus is gonna win
this again or is he side jinx him Oh may
this coming this or this is meet next
move he can't sit can you take here only
move Wow I know he's gonna win it's hard
to it's hard to meet with like a second
left when black through his random moves
I was incredible he was getting smashed
yeah welcome everyone I'm gonna try and
save I'm gonna straighten try and stay
focused on the chest hey you got Jess
welcome back thanks for subbing so this
is this was some sort of like Queen's
Indian type thing this mean compared to
the previous two games the King is much
safer here on g2 very positional now and
he's already won Connect four
yeah 3307 the the highest rating ever
reach s I think he's he's only gaining
what like two or three points per win
yeah so Magnus is point Grandmaster
Sergei zag all ko I still don't know if
it's is a Galka or she call Co let's
call him Sergei hey-oh though low B yeah
yeah I believe this is a record it was
posted on reddit maybe an hour ago that
Carlson dropped 30 300 she's been
playing a lot of bullet today oh that's
a fork oh but that Brookes pinned
there's so many counter counter tactics
but look at the time Carlson's up 38 oh
that's a tactic
it's up 30 seconds and winning on the
board so the previous game we saw a
fried liver is he gonna repeat the
opening no probably good choice so now
it's just kind of a positional Italian
yeah he's I guess he's won he's running
a few more in a row but this match he's
won four in a row
that's a nice I was gonna say that was a
nice Bishop now he's going for maybe
this sort of King side attack like the
knight and the bishop want to coordinate
surprise he didn't go for this earlier
maybe g3 was possible now white wants to
maybe play off four and attack on the
Kings side yeah you have to be careful I
would be terrified here as black like
these two kind of half open files but
maybe now's the time oh but there's my
g5
hey dougie how's it going tugging I saw
tigey here but I see tally saying hey
chat uh yeah this is all alive this is
real time may be delayed by a few
milliseconds oh this is a very nice
square the Queen defends a knight but
maybe Bishop team won at some point
john-john's welcome back still first
nice job
thanks John John's hey Walker boy
reading with par you six whoa what's
going on blocks losing a queen but he's
off on time again he just take takes
takes takes weird stuff is happening
white wants to meet
oh but likes playing for a win maybe
rook yeah I was gonna say rook here well
it seems so oh he gets he gets mated oh
the reading his beautiful reading he
just lost
you just lost six points right I was his
first loss this uh at least this match
lysimeter thanks for subbing also shout
out to Walker boy thanks again for the
raid Mika was a sound too low sound
looks okay
I can turn up the volume of the moves Oh
[Music]
minus 9 oh so he was yet 3310 you guys
didn't acknowledge it hey alright
welcome back the right is slight ah oh
yeah maybe I was streaming early on
chess calm way out got a little bit off
this looks ok now
oh thanks so much
Jeong jeong's 500 bits okay hopefully
this looks okay myself a little bit
bigger whoa
I look away for a few seconds okay this
looks crushing for a white like just
take upon and mate oh but you have to be
careful cuz Queen takes with check but
Knight f6 there's two different threats
oh it's like there is one mate where
Kramnik ground I lost to a computer like
with a knight on the back ring very
similar type of pattern okay this game
Magnus playing some kind of old Indian
what we call this maybe it's just called
an old Indian Walker boy shot that again
- Walker boy oh maybe the voice of AI
the voice is loud - or too pious Walker
boy which is better leech ass or a star
star star yeah something like the
hyperlinks won't work unless you're a
mod or VIP I think my rating is too low
to play Magnus a aurash thanks for the
500 bits in John John's with 998 bits
thanks so much everyone
yeah today today's a very rare day today
at least earlier i streamed on jaws calm
and now it's all me just stream I don't
know now's the best time to sleep
the match is just beginning but thanks
for the bits I appreciate it yeah it's
made media it's late for some people
it's 8:05 p.m. in st. Louis which means
Alexa what time is it in Norway
in Norway I assume that's where at least
Carlson is oh it's a perpetual it's the
first draw ever so Magnus is now back to
the magical 3300 now hey it's a wing
gambit we saw this saw this other day um
he was playing against I think it was
against Sergei he may have played
against Perugia - this looks really nice
for light a way more development at the
cost of only upon I wonder if Magnus
could literally beat me in his sleep
that's why you have to social distance
don't fall asleep near - they're near
dangerous people anyway ok the pawn is
pushing Oh Bishop e7 and now two things
are attacked so White's just roll but
the knight hung it's still weird maybe
you work here but why can Queen okay so
the Queen's got trade in Bishop c6 isn't
coming and still rookie HS wins ouch
did that not make any sense nothing
makes sense anymore what's nine of five
ah you're a kid so you have to sleep all
thanks thanks again have a good night's
whoa rookie gate ok so there's been a
few games where Carlson has refutes
refused to castle being adventurous with
his king the king is playing a role
defending the bishop ooh the pawn has
vanished and c5 can always reinforce in
the case of rook t1 she worked he won
maybe just hang on f3 c5
oh we're not
but still looks decent for black extra
pawn everything was defended the King's
now safe baby Queen f7 or c6 you just
want to defend everything you take your
you can take there's this pin takes with
rook Wow
so maybe rook e8 I'm not sick I'm just
it's been a lot of talking today I'm
kind of losing my voice I have some
allergies to I forgot to make tea what
does [ __ ] would be five so that was
just a fancy trade buck still up upon
bishops attacking from behind doesn't
help though so 3304 so question for the
chat at the end of this match what will
the the new rating record be cuz right
now it was what was it 3310 so how high
will Magnus goggle 3350 well we see 3400
that's that but that would have to take
what at least 50 wins in a row
quintuple adoption Wow a lot of 33
numbers in the chat also this look at
this position ooh
Knights pin to the pawn are we gonna see
like some smother mates Mirai that would
be so thrilled like take stakes by five
maybe 37 nice move miss Rooke t1 yeah
reinforce everything
3950 we want to see a smothered mate Oh
or queen sac that's that's suitable
that's really nice whites so close to
meeting here we'll get the Knights
attacked but where's the mate well now
there's a pin wow it's a queen sac but
does it work I don't think it works
that's not check needs
oh he just sacked a screen I thought he
I think he thought it was gonna be made
that's not made and now he has to run
it's built for it dirty flag six seconds
for Chicago to win this just got a spite
check ya g6o if I could move Carlson
resigns back below 3,300 what does the
lowest will see Carlson did - ooh it's a
track sir
Karl something the tracks are gambit
this is a cool opening
yes Sergei played the more solid Bishop
takes f7 but this is still fun I don't
have ever seen
Carlson play a track sir a chap must see
this must be so proud now Nick knack
yeah the knick-knack whatever that was
did not work the previous game in g6
Oh is he getting needed this is just
meat right no it's not coz Keaney ate
yeah it's important to identify mates in
one and if this says Queen f2 surprise
maybe the king wants to run this way
this is so confusing both nights a queen
the King on d7 White's King is so safe
oh is key nice was Bishop e6 I don't
know because King takes and then the
knight would be attacked
yeah b5 wait what white resigned
white resigns what just happened the
position was so confusing
oh the Queen was hanging the knight was
hanging and why it was already down like
a rook okay fair enough so White's yeah
somehow Carlsen one that I don't know
where white went wrong but it was
confusing maybe he was also flagging
okay so this is way more positional very
typical structure where like black has
more space with these pawns but white
has a clear target it's very hard to
respond to advance the knight hopping
around probably kind to f4
Oh a GFI prevent sense white wants to
hop hop back around it's a little bit
cramped relate the rook is now attack
tricky too it was not a great position
for someone who's claustrophobic yeah
Magnus took needs to win a very high
percentage to just stay level with
rating it's insane like he'll he he wins
against someone over a 3,000 mile gain I
think like two or three points aha
so II for now f4 Wow so he's just trying
to open the kingside thank you we might
see this maneuver ah so you wanted to
play Queen g5 not each one I did want to
tag in the pawn which can't be defended
you just take the pawn that slice he
wins another pawn so it's equal material
oh he had this movement and fork don't
know if that would have won anything on
them the king is so much more active
yeah I just take stuff it's so far ahead
on time we need so in a four-to-one any
percent some smash and Jerry for prize
yeah it's my pleasure
whoa what just happened oh there's a
pawn the c5
the hairs of Bishop on cinephile joking
thanks for the bits so okay it's boom
it's an exchange sac but not really
cause if takes rook to e8 and lights
gonna be loose the Queen can't defend
both the rook in the lights that's very
nice
so black has to miners for a rook no now
actually Knight and Bishop and pawn for
a rook and everything's defended and
just take that take that I don't know if
you saw that the Queen was defended by
the pawn
oh yeah the gamut from a few games ago
is called the Traxler not an opening
that you see the world champion play
every day okay we have the Kings Indian
[Music]
or English of some sorts like this idea
use that file I'd be very tempted to
just sack he might want to prepare it
yeah AG for Bishop yeah the bishops
gonna come in very soon
why yeah she winds up on that's nice
while the nights are tough both nights
are hanging and the Queens attacked and
the pawns just chillin yeah weights
what's up way too much material I mean
black wants to like perpetual but
there's no hope or is there there's
Nathan one threat oh wow
just as I say that it's tricky he has to
give away a rook but then White's gonna
be on the offensive you have to take the
rook
that's nice attacking the rook
pressuring the bishop oh you can't play
Bishop a6 is still mate maybe rook g5 f
g5 and you're gonna hope the checks work
out
oh he just wins everything
God that was mate I wasn't nice mate he
could I would have just taken the night
but that's a really beautiful mate
vision d5 it's just a bishop in there
look working together hey it's another
Traxler so tracks are number two this is
very risky opening for black is the
Queen to the Queen got trapped both has
gambits tracks are gambit followed by
boat s candidates he has two minors for
the Queen this looks terrible for black
I don't know why I should be excited
about this but let's see can Carlsen
survive down a queen for a night in
bishop actually Queen and pawn 419
Bishop I mean the problem is like though
once there's an open file it's gonna be
hard to deal with the battery what to do
he just kind of has to wait yeah he's
just moving back and forth but though
the one hope is tying this looks too
painful though maybe this move unleash
an attack this the problem is the Queen
hinges move back call the Queen g3 the
Brookes tied down
but Layton was back I mean whites
clearly playing for a win
triple battery the alkynes gun it's a
deadly weapon oh that was a nice double
attack yeah once the pond falls this is
not easy but somehow he's still like
he's keeping everything defended we knew
it was a threat your ruca feet 9f8 all
yes to do is not getting needed for a
few more seconds
whoo and he won he won the rook he's
still alive somehow like losing
everything and he's up about 4 seconds
any one thing he would just won all the
pieces he won two queens that was a
counter counter boat has countered
double bow tez he just dropped all the
Queens Wow so he he won that how do you
win that no respect yeah I was
impressive he just kept surviving until
white gave away everything and was
flagging what a game so back to this
game again this is another game I feel
like in more than half of these games
Carlsen isn't castling but kind of fake
hassling a very adventurous with the
king with these pawns so majestic such
space and to bishops yeah the double
fiend cat of east six maybe he six I
guess allows 906
this is a very nice ending because the
deep Hans passed the bishops do damage
maybe this in this the rook wants to
join the party this is nice move it's
hard to actually like target the pawns
black is black heating the pawns mean
castling is is generally a good idea it
does depend on the position on the
opening but usually you you want to do
it in most cases but still takes work
for luck to win or Ferrara for white to
win lots of hard bishops oh he just
dropped a rook I don't think he was
expecting rook c8 oh he dropped a bishop
- wow so he I guess he returned the gift
hey Evans gambit I'm yeah that was very
uncorrelated little 3,300 I think we're
gonna see a lot of fluctuation a
profit-sharing shout out to Gotham chess
how's it going I got a big dolphin
command it has been nice to see
Carlson's preparation against Evans
gambit but honestly this position does
not look so impressive
what is this position you're not
developed you're not even up a pawn
weights pieces just seem way more active
but I guess the one benefit if these
pawns got traded why it will have an IQ
p some potential weakness mm-hmm welcome
back hun guy yeah and for she I did I
did great twenty hundred yesterday in
bullets but it's still too low to to
play Magnus has like a close to 500
point lead over me okay what else amines
nice move threatening mates
Bishop c2o so simple removal of the
guard I think this just wins apiece
cousin I can't move cuz rookie one I was
surprising in a hundred game bullet
match against Magnus how many games you
win I've already played them three games
all of which were bullet one was was
bullet chess960 and I'm two out of three
so I would hope out of all hundred I
would at least win - I think - is a safe
estimate we'll see or we can just
extrapolate and yeah say about 67 wins
but probably not in chess maybe in
Scrabble or maybe in geoguessr would
stand a better chance what does this
position three pieces were just hanging
you just take full decision you can't
take the rook because it's pinned this
seems so scary but Knight g3 will be a
nice defensive move rook takes f2 allows
Queen digs f2o f3 the counter-attack
that was nice
so kamikaze the Queen blocks up a minor
piece but down a ton of time another one
of these situations where Magnus just
has to survive for not too many seconds
for Knights so box simplifying it's not
easy though that has no passed pawns in
seven seconds and this pawns hanging at
Magnus calculating the rest of the game
probably
what oh he lost connection no come back
we're so lonely da he flags
did he flag he Flags was it like a rage
quit cuz he lost a beef on connection
issues probably that's so sad
that's really sad what to do yeah really
what to do both players now offline so
we all just rage quit do i rage end my
stream